this statement is read out on behalf of
the families of Kelly Brewster Megan
Hurley Haley McLeod Chloe Rutherford and
Liam Curry
firstly we would like to personally
thanks Sir John and the inquiry legal
team for arranging these three days of
follow-up hearings it has proved to be
both informative and absolutely
necessary to ensure that the
recommendations that were set out have
been highlighted and to check whether
any of them have been fulfilled
our families have been present in court
every day of the inquiry and listen to
failing after failing from all involved
on that terrible night of the 22nd of
May 2017.
we welcome each and every recommendation
made by Sir John to try and make our
country a safer place and to prevent
more families finding themselves in our
horrific position in the future
we were present this week with the hope
that our government and Emergency
Services will have at least begun to
change and Implement these
recommendations
sadly that has not been the case for so
many of them
some like greater Manchester fire and
rescue service have embraced the
recommendations and have moved swiftly
to ensure that all have been implemented
in fact they have gone beyond the
recommendations in some situations and
we thank them for that however other
blue light services and indeed our
governments have yet to show enough
improvements phrases like we aspire to
just aren't good enough actions need to
be taken so that when this happens again
there is a very different outcome and
other families won't have to go through
the Heartbreak we have
some of the recommendations made such as
the Gap in bleed control training for
First Responders that was clear
following the 22nd of May 2017 and we
are astounded to hear that six years on
this is not still fully embedded within
the police and we call for this to
happen without any further delay
we can only hope that all the inquiry
recommendations are implemented speedily
sadly when inquiries end there normally
is no follow-up process once again we
must thank Sir John and the inquiry
legal team for securing some follow-up
this week
we are absolutely devastated that there
won't be another hearing to follow-up
progress in the future given the amount
of outstanding recommendations from so
many of the services
we hope that all those still outstanding
recommendations will be implemented at
speed and would ask that all relevant
Services keep the families updated at
regular intervals be that privately or
via our legal teams
sadly we have little faith that changes
will we follow through and we publicly
challenge the services to prove us wrong
and that's that the government look at
changing the legislation for inquiries
to have the ability to monitor
recommendations at regular intervals to
ensure that each and every service is
held to account fully
we have found the evidence this morning
in particular to be absolutely
heartbreaking
listening to the evidence from the
department of social social care this
morning make excuses as to why over six
years since our families were ripped
apart the changes that need to be made
to make venues safer are still not
happening was awful to hear
as the chairman pointed out this morning
the government are legally responsible
for the health and safety of every
person in this country and if these
venues are not providing an adequate
level of care to those present because
recommendations have not been
implemented then ultimately those
responsible for this failure including
the government should be held to account
the inquiry process for us has been
about understanding what happened but
also crucially to ensure that real
change is made to make others safer our
plea to the government now is please
don't forget us and our loved ones names
that do the right thing in their memory
finally on behalf of all the 11 families
that we represent we want to thank the
chair and the inquiry legal team for all
they have done and we want to pay
tribute to the dignity and bravery of
each and every one of our clients who
have given so much of their time and
commitment to the inquiry process in the
name and memory of their loved ones we
Echo our clients plea for all the
recommendations made by Sir John to be
implemented without delay thank you
but because
sorry sorry
it's okay
the place that the Manchester Arena
inquiry has now concluded on the whole
we are happy with the progress that has
been made by the different agencies
involved since the beginning of the
inquiry in September 2020 having said
that it is clear that more work needs to
be done by some organizations and some
have further to go than others the way
the inquiry has been conducted has
restored our faith in humanity and it is
important for us to put on record our
gratitude to the people who have ensured
this difficult period has been handled
with kindness and patience we want to
once again thank Sir John Saunders the
entire inquiry team our legal team our
barristers including John Cooper used
Casey and the other families who have
provided us with support and kindness
throughout this process
Martin's death has irrevocably changed
our lives the inquiry has been a
necessary process to participate with
today's conclusion will leave me with
the space to focus on the next stage of
my life implementing Martin's law into
the UK legislation we don't want any
other family any other parents sibling
or friend going through what the 22
families have experienced since the
Manchester Arena attack I'm therefore
determined to help the government and
businesses to introduce the necessary
measures to prevent terror attack
yesterday I gave evidence to the home
Affairs Select Committee in Parliament
as Martin's logos through the
pre-legislative scrutiny stage over the
coming weeks and months I plan to
continue meeting with businesses and
security industry experts to promote the
significance Martins law will have in
terms of protecting our communities from
Terror attacks I look forward to the
government introducing the legislation
into a later year thank you
Adventure